guess what guys what's up man
Mother's Day is coming out and I have
some photos that I want a frame I don't
know where to go I have an idea or frame
bridge calm is right now what that is
don't hold that yeah don't hold back
it's a place where you can print and
frame it's like a one-stop shop for all
photo gifts yeah and you know what I
highly recommend it because it's like I
went to a frame shop once and I drop it
off we'll have it to you in two weeks
I was like nah this is actually the
truth he's not there's not a like all
the artworks out yeah I do a lot and so
now I go to frame bridge it's quick how
quick like ring real quick quick really
like real quick quick and with us you
get 15% off whoa so what's the Mother's
Day special George uh well the Mother's
Day special is good damn it
get it together George you're the one I
always talked about Mother's Dale every
year yeah don't you love your mother
George uh well the key is don't forget
for Dunaway I'll tell what is it don't
get stuck searching for last-minute
gifts order now for Mother's Day
Delivery 15% off your first order and
free shipping okay oh man I forgot my
mom's birthday so I think I need to do
something for an ounce oh that's a good
idea
you guys make sure you go to frame
bridge calm and use the promo code belly
and you'll save an additional 50% off
your first order so go to frame bridge
calm promo code belly and that is one
more time frame bridge comm from bed
hungry
[Music]
psychopaths yeah ready ready four three
two all right class why are we obvious
notice as we go okay just you kill
everyone clap your hands cut them like
you just don't care
everyone clap your hands clap your goat
okay don't even [ __ ] know the rocking
mirror thing you're [ __ ] right you're
right anyway well welcome to Tiger belly
my name is Captain Bob Lee and we have
kalila George's here Gilbert's here and
let me tell you something right now
I was afraid to ask this next guy to do
the podcast because he has gone into a
different threshold of existence and he
used to be with the with me we're still
together I got it as a no we're just you
know me comedy compadres you know and um
he's moved on to a different level and
I'm so happy that he's here his name is
Eric stone Eric's just treat Eric's
toast with everybody from the Modern
Family
yes yeah modern we're just gonna do the
Asian accent no you taught me I know I
taught him how to do an Asian accent and
also I am only impersonating you in
person and the reason why I asked I got
the balls because you know Eric texted
me in once a year twice a year and he
sent me this photo it says it's a photo
of the Hollywood ball and it says the
Korea Times presents 2017 Korean music
festival and then he just put FYI
hahaha like for like I'm gonna [ __ ]
buy ticket I don't like like the Rolling
Stones yeah like you would just be given
tickets Yeah right how you get is no
excess right kitty backstage pass pass
ta and we're first of all can I just say
that then you know there's that I'm an
American just like you are you a little
bit because when you came to the house
would you say this is nice no I didn't
say that thank you
two boys shoes that run I know well so
that was because you saw this to choose
yeah I wanted to be respectful I [ __ ]
hate when people make you take off your
shoes when you go to ride do you make
people do that no I would never make you
do that and then when you drove you go
we would just say well you will good no
bigot irrigated people if you want to
know our relations okay are really hard
hit it Eric and I we we joke around
right and we have uh we have an open
kind of a comedy relationship well we
could say whatever to each other yeah
correct
and so when I pulled into your parking
garage you said what you say this is a
very expensive car yeah I was just
saying I want to make sure it's a but I
didn't have to say that I know you and I
know I know
and then um I'd like to talk about
mm-hmm the beginning yeah of you and I
I'll be interested to see what if your
story minute is my story I think that I
met you at the commercial audition for
Pepsi one for perhaps eight for Michael
Bay the one he directed did you guys
book it well whatever was in when I were
like rumor downtown yeah in that Lobby
la centre studio right and we were
looking each other do we say I don't
think anyone said hey I'm Bobby and I'm
Eric I think we just were friendly to
each other yeah but we knew that there
was one part yeah and then they were bit
and what are you were going for the same
parts over the last two right yeah weird
their lives they had released one guy
who I was so like I always felt bad for
the guys it's like thank you so much
yeah because I was that guy plenty -
yeah I know you were uh yes I was a lot
I was I know yeah so you would I like
that guy a lot Oh son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh you
okay so [ __ ] you and so we looked each
other he did said he would go in and so
now Michael Bay is sitting there with
like four or five guys and they look
cool yeah that well there ya are they
are cool right there sitting there their
legs you know they they cross their legs
sit like this yeah their hair
/ / Harris perfect and I swore to
[ __ ] god all I heard was crush like
laughter oh and then when you know you
know you got this guy he's probably the
best he is I'm not going to get it but I
went in there I did okay yeah I heard
laughter and you went in - yeah yeah and
then they would bring Erick back in
right and back and forth when you hear
more laughing and here what yeah and
they would bring him back in and so was
I got a little kind of a laugh ah it was
brutal it was brutal yeah yeah and then
they brought us in together well don't
you remember we were both sitting there
they were both sitting in the lobby or
whatever yeah and at that moment in time
we probably were talking like dude this
is weird like whoever gets it whatever
yeah and then they pop their head out
there like we'd like you to both come in
right never happens and didn't they just
kind of hire us right there again yeah
yeah you're both gonna be the guy yeah
you're both are gonna be the guy but
then it became when we actually did the
job go on yeah it was a disaster for me
why for you already for I was in deep
water number one it was a Super Bowl
commercial yeah yeah it was so thick
yeah yeah it was a spoof on Goldilocks
and the three bears
right and Kim Cattrall was Goldilocks
and Bobbie and I were the towel boy
however was right and you have to
understand this and Eric's worked with
me a couple of times on different things
it's a emerges I was young and I yeah I
don't know why you're not we have sense
cause we have classic revolt yeah i
mutilated those yeah how is that you can
keep it current I mean and I tell you
love the panic that I get yeah I all
those thing and why don't the real is a
reoccurring nightmare he or not they're
not I'll say yeah they're not yeah it is
to live I still talk about it I do too
yeah I think it's like I when I get big
jobs and a room big people I panic and I
go through the you know people that are
fans of the podcast know how weird I am
and that all is real yeah it is Raya
yeah it is yeah yeah so I've got the
nice item ease always told you that it's
misplaced because you are not in those
places by accident you are that
challenge at all
thank you that you need to fall back on
that every once in a while
except when I'm giving you [ __ ] yes and
that's really nice that you would say
that I would what the credit you said
something like that but anyway let's
move on from that let's not go yet I get
to cook [ __ ] comfortable so do you
remember though how difficult it was for
me to because we're shooting the
commercial and Michael would come over
and say alright it's the light thing
going to go off this time and then the
cameras going to be on the track right
it's going to do this and then we're
going to do that alright then he would
look at me and be like all right uh
you're hilarious just keep doing what
you're doing you Bobby stay in the
[ __ ] light if I can't see your face
you're not going to be on camera do you
understand that and it just would berate
Bobby yeah and then compliment me there
we messed thing and then I wasn't away a
bit no no no boy he grabbed my face ha
ha he grabbed my he went from behind the
camera Michael Bay grabbed my face and
goes the light the light right I mean I
kept looking at Eragon look this is the
worst yeah but to be fair like why
couldn't you just be like yeah well why
not keep not getting your faith in the
light because I never really I mean that
was like what my third or fourth job
yeah but oh my god so we had to do this
a little comedy comedy thing where I
would peek around the corner and then
Bobby would peek underneath me or I
would seek down and Bobby would be
correct you know yeah you know this kind
of yeah and you could never get your
face in the light and then do you
remember what else happened when we were
shooting that commercial but no not a
better ad about oh yeah oh yeah
I know Michael Parkinson showed up yeah
so we're having lunch leathers lunch
yeah
and now at this point I just I mean I'm
not outwardly saying it by I'm sure he's
news I was just this is the worst I hate
it you know and as like I quit whatever
arrived and then we're having lunch and
then this out of nowhere a gigantic
gorilla gorilla yeah we can sell it was
because he was in plan of it he came in
in full full man yeah I'm not calling
Michael okay I know my god he would say
this I'm called bugle rumor yeah
very gently form second city this one
yeah perfectly though oh not yeah I
lived there for two years yeah
wasn't he came in gorilla suit when he
said that when you said that Wrigley
Field he wasn't that impressive but I
get lone million hell hole it's like
next to I really uh okay yeah anyway way
to pump the brake um so yeah he came in
and everyone Michael like touching his
and he made him like do a cry anyone Oh
beating his chest agree I yeah yeah
yellow eyes yeah amazing anyway that
commercial didn't run that much and then
but he was what do you remember this
well at the end of the commercial go on
you and I was standing next to each
other
Kim Cattrall walks up to you do you
remember this oh and says you're gonna
be a very big star she said that to me
yes and why did she say to you she
looked at me said nothing and walked
away
and she was right hahahaha she was a lot
of things have happened with me though
you're in here with me I know you met I
know so you guys have this picture where
your dresses mimes where's that from
oh that's where you're sitting on my lap
that's my BM commercial knows another I
think we were bank robbers yeah you guys
are like a duo for a while you don't
know how many dozen ran I think in the
late nineties yeah early - we ran there
was like ten guys that booked every
commercial yeah yeah I mean I would book
I mean I literally look 20 in a year hey
you didn't tell me off like that's your
record
hahaha that's how many how many joke
quick commercial did you do it how many
like forever yep from do your whole
career I guess if you don't know Jill
picker is the he's like the Steven
Spielberg of commercial director yeah
he's he's you when you book a kill pick
a job you're gonna go through hell I
mean at least I did but you're gonna
make a shitload of mine good and he's he
likes finding people that he likes and
can trust and yeah it works with
many just keeps casting him and I was
lucky enough I think in two thousand
maybe two thousand to book my first
America one with him which was an
American Express commercial and I think
between men and 2007 I did like sixty oh
my god
well I remember you were in Italy
shooting one with them both yeah the
country right yeah it was shooting a
commercial for IBM in front of the
Leaning Tower of Pisa and it the Leaning
Tower of Pisa tumbled crashed to the
ground and the commercial ran exactly
two times on nine nine and nine ten of
2001 ah what happened at eleven sabe Oh
I'll leave that disastrous apnea so that
that commercial never really really did
much yeah by in retrospect was uh yeah
exactly yeah yeah I got to go to Italy
yeah and you I remember one night you
said you had kids to pick ax I mean this
he was he was nice to you right very
nice yeah
but to me it was nice to you to he kept
hiring you that means he likes you I
know but the things he would say though
well you don't bring those on at all
examples the abuse was my opinion of
that what you just said right now it
could have been a spiritual awakening
just now really because in many ways I
like to blame people mm-hmm but I have
to look at my behavior you do and and I
acted I had to look at the things that I
say and and I am and do and things I
invite and you know what that's too
shady you my friend you could be right
about that
but he did system crazy [ __ ] yeah like
what
ching-chong I'm doing real Jim come get
on your bar yeah yeah yeah but I've
heard him say he doesn't discriminate he
doesn't ya know he says crazy things
about a lot of things yeah and he's the
best in the business and I made a lot of
money and they thank you so much mr.
picker yeah he's my he is really
literally one of the people responsible
for me to be able to be in the position
to even get a job like modern family
because when I would go into auditions
because of working for him consistently
I was you know secure like I felt secure
and I felt like I had confidence because
I had a
few Duckett's in the bank and I didn't
have to go in there with desperation
pouring out of my pores yeah yeah you're
right I don't know he was like I did one
job for him an IBM job I made three
hundred thousand dollars for one job and
this is in 1999 no I didn't make that
much on one which one was that it was a
juggernaut with the space suit one oh
that was a huge huge campaign yeah yeah
so I guess I'm just grateful for yeah
yeah for all that and even when I was on
that I did the bank robber on with you
remember yeah at the shaved head yeah
that was great I was Gwen that's when we
did that I forgot about that one
yeah that's it with me little that's the
one you're talking about where you sit
on my lap or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah we are I'm wearing a little pork
pie hat yeah yeah and then you did a
completed like a couple of mad sketches
right me one one you with you and Ike
would mean I bear whole cuz I knew like
from Chicago yeah I knew you from here
and then you know what I was so number
as week we go did like Steve and I would
go to that Brazilian or that Brazilian
run I got in Burbank yeah yeah which one
is it that sure is Korea yeah it's a
trois Korea is called meet wouldn't call
this yeah me yeah I can't remember what
it's called it's over in the media
center like downtown Burbank but yeah we
went to there remember you just do the
green light right you ate so much do I
would call you being mad at me because I
did an interview or something where I
said that I call Eric Stonestreet to get
me like good restaurants no I would
never be mad why would I I think you
gave me [ __ ] was at you or not somebody
not me oh that yeah when did you do an
interview hahahahaha I'm saying that
enough have you done interviews yeah
like who knows interviewed you uncover
like Korea m3 yeah so but what are you
talking about I don't I don't know I did
like I did like a some sort of like
interview and I said that what do you
get because I remember I talked to you I
said I bought tinder I caught him on
tinder own and then I said hey I heard
about the speak after you deli yeah in a
sec number I taught you about anger yeah
did and you got off at inion I did get
off of it for a while the same old same
same thing it's like a game like I
didn't what not I mean meeting people
because I barely meet people off the
dating apps but just swiping people's
pictures it just feels like I'm playing
some sort of game and you become
desensitized and it's a polymer you
wanna seven years yeah yeah no year
whatever yeah what did you go on a date
on it yeah yeah of course but it was
cool for really over a while yeah yeah
you you definitely got me going on that
yeah cuz I heard that way did you really
yeah I didn't see one man I missed my
chance Sharon we'd be doing this podcast
together big room remedy commercial yeah
more IBM than him I used to kill it like
he used to do at that I know he's
killing it now but like even I mean you
have to imagine a guy who you know you
don't really know his name but you just
know when he walks into a commercial you
know auditioning room you go oh [ __ ]
that guy I feel that people thought that
about me I think they do I think they do
because I've heard other people say yes
those who used to come in and used to
get it and then you know men I hope and
they never get nice there were guys that
didn't get would go in and never got any
yeah imagine going in to 50 of them and
then seeing you at half of them and then
you're on half of those out you know in
his hand he's like that guy's a beast
but there were people like that when I
moved out here that I would see in every
commercial yeah I would walk in it took
a while for me to get to be considered
that guy god you use it you're really
humble or not I am I think so you are
yeah what were you doing immediately
before you got cast on Modern Family
um commercials like mostly just
commercials I had done a few guest stars
leading up in that year on TV shows
where I'd killed killed a few people
Bobby knows my dark side yeah but he
also was on roofies like almost same as
it was in that yeah a small part
you have a cigarette yeah I'm yet to
imagine when I was watching that movie
back in the day algebra zap yeah but I
was in one of my down you know like
little funks as an actor right before
modern family you know how we go through
those things where you're just like well
what do I do now and I was literally in
one of those in a friend of mine who I
met through Joe Pitka
Marshall Bell I don't know if you ever
worked with Marshall Bell he's a
character actor talks like this he's
from Oklahoma Lakes his teeth a lot and
I called him and I was like dude I'm
having he's like what else you gonna do
man you got traction you're in the
business you got to stay whoa he talked
me he like talked me down off the good
ledge Wow he's like what else can you do
well yeah yeah well Jesus I guess when
you put it that way
yeah so and then the audition for Modern
Family happened like within that form a
four-month window of that period and I
read that that whole audition process
was a long one for you where they kind
of didn't know like who they wanted to
cast with their girlfriends so much
smarter than you she does return she
seems good yeah I got okay okay that
[ __ ] answer it man that's [ __ ]
tendrá didn't you baby so much hey I'll
talk about it out hey now I'm sweating
yeah okay well take the [ __ ] stocking
cap oh yeah right I did all that hair so
yeah it was well because I was one of
the last people that they'd cast in the
show they had been looking for a while
and I did you know for auditions for
which isn't that that unusual but what
made my process a little more unusual
was that they had done two auditions and
they had passed like sent word like they
liked me but it wasn't going to go any
further because I knew I knew the
casting director and so it was a
courtesy call for him calling my manager
because you know as actors we'd love to
know when we're no longer and so we're
not sitting home wondering so he just
called and said hey you know they really
like Derek but it's not it's not going
to go any further twice they did that to
me oh my god so that was what made my
product that process for me a little
different and then then you could then
the third time did you go I'm not going
to go
again or well no then they called out of
the blue and said we'll test you so then
so I went once past then ten days seven
days passed and they called back and
said come back in dress more
appropriately for the character
clean-shaven because I would roll around
that's another thing I would do I'd love
to buy you yeah I would never like dirty
play the play the game of doctors coat
oh yeah I like they drag yeah yeah
whenever to say I used to get when I
first moved into town like the only
Asian one so I'd go to a lobby and tall
people ninja suits
yeah in samurai someone I would dress
like this yeah I gamma cutting I guess I
knew it was time for me to start getting
thinking about getting out of the
commercial business when I went over to
an audition in Santa Monica and it
called for a guy in a suit and tie and I
showed up you know just in like a nice
shirt and jeans yeah I wasn't looking
like a slob and the guy was like oh what
he here for
and I said Sears he's like where's your
suit and tie and I said oh do they have
the set build in there too he's like
what I said did they build the set do we
is the set in there yeah you have no
imagination yeah yeah yeah so I was like
I need to back away I'm loose well
twelve years of Vince's come on yeah
yeah yeah but anyway I was just doing
commercials and I remember distinct
distinctly shooting the pilot and
listening to all my co-stars talking
about their careers and the things that
they had and that includes the kids on
the show and everyone had something that
they were either going to do if the show
didn't get picked up or that they had
turned down to do the show like Julie
Bowen was in second position on another
pilot Ty Burrell was in second position
on another pilot Sofia Vergara had a
holding deal at ABC Jesse Tyler Ferguson
was going to go to Broadway and play
buddy the elf in the musical elf Mario
winter who's a brilliant actress she had
something that she was going to do Rico
was like killing it and doing his own
thing everybody had something going on
and I really remember sitting there
thinking I have a Lowe's callback yeah
but that was my that was my career Pinet
to that point and I think I represented
so many actors to that point I was the
guy who I was the least known a adult
for sure
maybe Arielle and Sarah Hyland were more
recognizable I mean they had worked more
than I had almost probably and that's
yeah but kind to say this the argument
is this though I don't you said all
those names I don't know who do you know
watch the show
I doesn't matter wait a minute what no I
don't know if you know you've never seen
modern face I guess he's pretty great
[ __ ] I know it's good [ __ ] geek is
it too hard for you as you were clip it
I saw one time you did that thing with
the baby up and you did a a Lion King
thing that was supposed to be you went
up there I know Bobby went over I
thought I asked on him twice no I saw
that you know how you you're I'm a I
protect my coach and I had one of those
little TV screens and nobody was next to
me seeing that part and then laughing
and I thought I want to say that's my
friend you know me but I didn't but I
laughed because the way you did was
funny and that's all interesting but
what I want to say it is he has a hard
time watching all right I can't feel you
but not even yourself at your friends
you can't do it okay
but just can I just say this sure is
that I don't know they are too fine I
know the guy from married with children
he's in it okay fine at Ted Bundy's and
murderers but I can I and people that
were in the comedy business right know
who you are and we think that you will
always thought I always thought that
you're legit yeah and that's when I give
a [ __ ] about yeah well they take when
like um you know one time I was at
Barnes & Noble and this is before I met
you sweetie I was with this girl at the
shitty days yeah and Chris Rock walked
up and said what's up dude give me a hug
and that's I don't care about if the
variety you mean knows me or whatever I
just care that that dude who's in the
same business as I am respects me or
knows who I am right I mean so I'd
rather have that well I would too when
you're in that [ __ ] show other like
show like modern family and I know
you're saying all those things that's
what you're thinking I have loads and
this is that
at the end of the day but you still had
the back edge of I think the comedy
community well that's very nice or was
it like I say one nice thing about you
and then you say something nice to me
that was really sweet no the hell I was
doing okay well I wasn't doing can I
thank you for saying something really
nice it's like two genuine moments I
have is that a rarity uh I could you're
weirded compliment we made like you know
we always made fun of each other yeah
yeah yeah
we don't go deep right what like what
knocking fun oh yeah no no no no yeah
it's not like you're going on deeper
than I have like which one am I gonna
that Bay says it all yeah you've sent me
some pictures that I didn't appreciate
oh I kind of look there I'm not going to
say any more about that yeah yeah all
right didn't care for that and wow I see
a little resentment still no not
resentment revenge anger what kind of a
boat baby not right now I don't want
this to turn into you know well that's
not on him that's on you for something
my bad I'm apologizing am i bad - lean
back George which is a little bit thank
you so much do you need it I'm nervous
don't be nervous
everyone back up he says Bobby
unsolicited dick fix all the time yeah
oh that's not what I'm talking about
okay okay what can I say something how
you help me I know I swear God you did
this and I don't know if you remember
but I was at an audition right yeah and
you were on the lot that's where you
shoot right yeah you walk into the lobby
right when I was auditioning and I was
telling you I was I was ego you said
something to me you said it doesn't have
to be perfect they know that you're a
human being that you just got the size
you're mean just do the best you can you
mean don't worry about you know I mean
it really put me in a different mental
state because I was always in a this
when I was on yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is your third year or something
second year so after one I mean I think
[Laughter]
yeah I was just yeah whatever yeah yeah
yeah and um anyway
go on any [ __ ] way it helped me and I
tested for that job but I'll it was
literally like yes I get a script I go
we all go into that mode we all get into
that mode that have to to you know
perfect it and what I always would tell
people is like you want to do the almost
the opposite of it when you go in an
audition because these people that go in
and audition and make it perfect you're
you're kind of setting the standard in
the people watching his mind that they
think well this is as good as it's going
to be this is as good as it can get
no reason for a hitch perfect yeah off
book off this and man there's this is
the performance right when you want to
give the appearance that you're a
performer and this is a loose sketch of
how good it can be and man wait till you
have some time with it wait till you
have a costume on wait till you have a
prop in your belt wait till you're on
set then it's going to really come alive
but these people that go in that are
super worried about being polished
you're kind of doing yourself a
disservice my trick in commercials and I
tell people this all the time and that
really I think was an important thing is
I would be so aloof in a commercial
audition I would walk in and I would be
like um where do you want me to stand
yes where okay stand here and Who am I
Who am I reading what do you want me to
read with you or with you okay good and
they'd be like are you ready somebody oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah am I ready I'm ready
and then I would just be like and yeah
like come to life and take direction and
take notes and then it was like a Matt
doing a magic trick a little bit in a
sense because I would set the
expectations low yeah I said in
commercial auditions is that the slate
you have to pretend that it's silly that
you've done it before that you're
grateful to be there but also I you know
I'm a busy guy like me kind of embody
those things so I would always make the
slate kind of funny I'm sure you would
what would you do like would they turn I
go which way right now turn backward you
know you know and then we're going to
incorporate Eric I would do this Eric
Stonestreet one more time please
Eric Stonestreet can you try without a
hesitation Eric Stonestreet okay thank
you so much
Oh Bobby yes p-please slavery's okey
turn around though you know my anytime I
do an Asian guy it's me impersonating
you impersonating my dad yeah I'm
standup
yeah you do sometimes come out to see me
that's really nice yeah yeah never you
called me out in the audience at one
point yeah in the main room with it yeah
yeah and you know like that I didn't
mind it but it's not my world because
I've always kind of regretted never
pursuing in trying to be a stand-up but
you could I mean out of anyone you could
have done it well then it was funny
because you still do kind of a live show
I do do a live show like I know that
because we have the same agents they
still CA yeah okay I'm still there to
verily yea tell em you talked to him
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah wanted please we
should do we should do is we should do a
show we should do something together
yeah yeah but I know that it's I've
talked to the PA department and they go
yeah Eric do in Australia doing these
question-and-answer Q&A days how does
that work like this it's like an open
format where I'm onstage I come out and
I do a little brief introduction of like
Who I am and why I'm there and you know
if you get laughs in the interest in the
introduction yeah big time because that
then yeah because they don't know what
they really bought a ticket for so
that's why today is like I bet you're
wondering what the [ __ ] did you buy a
ticket for yeah yeah big rapidly don't
ya know and it's a combination of humor
instant and sincerity me giving advice
what I I found that people are always
asking me for an I buy something so and
then asking me what it's like to do what
I do so I've taken that format and just
turned it into a kind of improvised
stand-up because I get I never know what
kind of questions I'm going to get I do
know what some of the questions are so I
have built-in answers for those so I've
written jokes essentially yeah I own
head because my experience is improv
never stand up yeah and
so you do an hour I've done two hours
yeah that's amazing yeah I it's
exhilarating I love it and it's a meet
and greet afterwards I'll do a meet and
greet depending on where the theater is
yeah and what the what's the only money
to do it but you know the thing of it is
yeah if I didn't want to do it I
wouldn't be there and that's sort of a
nice thing about the job I have and
that's what I tell people it's like if
you see me someplace it's because I want
to be yeah I'm here tonight you don't
need the bunny yeah yeah I'm I like you
and you wanted to do this like I don't
go places I don't want to go and I don't
do shows that I don't want to do why
right no I mean and it's also gives them
like imagine living in a different
country and a modern a family where the
biggest it comes right and a huge I mean
my own my family from the Philippines
yeah it's huge ooh did I bus there do
you know already knows English yeah yeah
and it's like he's coming to our town
yeah yeah I mean I yeah I think it's
amazing that I like I did like six shows
last summer this time of year last last
year on the East Coast I like playing
those like 1300 seat theaters like those
that you I know you said no I do 250 250
2,500 or 250 - yeah can we hear you
little boys out - wait you tell you why
I know everybody knows you're just about
my journey my friend keep your pants on
right sorry I remember uh the Spaghetti
Factory
Oh Mike Burke again a birthday for
everyone has a Bobby Lee security
factory story oh really yeah yeah why
used to have the art well you came right
who is there
uh the only person I really remember
being there is you your brother and Ari
Shaffir Shaffir yeah yeah yeah yeah and
now because I think he I thought he was
funny then yeah I think he's so funny
man so funny now this is before he beat
the [ __ ] out of me or after did you guys
ever make up yeah okay he called me out
of the blue that's nice yeah if you guys
don't know this a lot of people do Ari
Shaffir beat the [ __ ] out of me
wrong point where I was bleeding anyone
because he just got tired of yourself or
what no no because of Natasha Leggero Oh
what happened I'm going to tell you the
quick story okay
um when I was on that do you remember
Ron Peterson Canadian guy well I was at
the Comedy Store one night and he goes
who's that on stage I thought that's
Natasha Leggero though she's hot I could
yeah but she lives with Ari Shaffir well
on Peterson goes alright and then I
walked away cuz I'd another show in the
man room whatever and then a couple
hours later I was driving him back to
the hotel aware you're saying anything
I got a number yeah but he's seeing
she's seeing my friend Ari it again but
she's gonna go up so she starts like
going to like plays with him dinners
behind all his back right and then out
of nowhere or he calls it she let me do
okay yeah but you could you shut them up
Oh God
right I go I didn't set them up what
would I do add because you get and
here's how I know you you did it I go
how if you don't do this for me right
now this thing I want to ask you to do I
know that you set them up whoa well is
it that was the thing Rachel I'm your
penis yes I know you do that that's free
yeah that's a Korean break into
something break into his office to get
to you you know go into this computer
you have to deal the emails between Ron
and estimate Ted Tasha so I go I can't
break into his [ __ ] office at MADtv
but can I just say the lies you will
love you with a little smoke I think in
a breaking my even yeah you thought
about it for I yeah I have my the whole
thing on yeah of the custom of bombs
okay
next book pops all right smoke but okay
I want to correct you on that and um so
I go now I'm not going to do that and he
goes Ben you set them up so that Friday
I show up at the Comedy Store and I'm
checking in at the front counter and he
punches me in the face
like for real punches this is not a
comedy fun comedy joke fight I fall to
the ground
and he kicks me in the face at 20 times
[ __ ] not bleeding I'm bleeding I'm like
you know almost you know coma but then
as I get up I hear my name being called
on stage and I go up on stage and did I
talk about it or I don't need it I only
went up for one minute yeah and I go
that guy right there
you know me I'm bleeding from the face
he pick Chad okay like I told him how I
scare right then I get offstage and the
manager goes just I mean he's just
emotional I'd do anything I go all right
how cool I am yeah
a week later I'm walking down the
hallway at the Comedy Store
[ __ ] right
he's are strangling me in the [ __ ]
hallway with this little Jews thumbs in
my throat and I don't mean that in a
racist way just a descriptive yeah but
I'm just saying that's how I thought at
the beginning the back pad any squeezing
and my neck starts bleeding because he
has his nails
I was into my [ __ ] neck why is the
funny baby explaining what is funny yeah
you're man bleep right so then and then
I remember I was dating a comic back
then and she was doing a show upstairs
Sarah did she come to your rescue
no she doesn't but I remember going
upstairs and my neck is bleeding she was
why are you crying
and why is your neck oh my god right I
bet that was a turn-on to her because I
was the beginning of the end
yeah sure then the worst thing happened
so then unbeknownst to me this is when
mind of Mencia was going on okay okay
Ari Shaffir head auditioned for mine and
Mencia and gotten the part when Carlos
Mencia was out of town so we had to
audition for the producer they had hired
him but then when the see account back
in the town he already knew that Ari had
attacked me twice and he was looking at
like who was performing in on a show and
he saw Ari on it yeah so he called Ari
Shaffir and said hey dude um you beat up
my friend Bobby so you can't do my show
so in all his mind he thought that I had
called oh no here comes the third thing
yeah yeah
this is a real bad secret before you
yeah yeah I'm so glad I didn't get ever
given yeah I would have beat your ass so
then I show up at the Comedy Store after
he gets fired from my demand CEO and I
just feel running right like I parked a
car I close the door I hear we up above
and then no running because he's in the
air in the Superman Brea just remember
behind pop I fall to the ground right I
just run straight to the office
screaming why what's so funny towards
nothing I work for this guy yeah I try I
try to call 9-1-1 what so i call 9-1-1
call the plane all right I answer the
phone and then nothing do you know why
Stephen is Izzy had pulled the [ __ ]
cord on a [ __ ] wall and he gets on
his hands and knees and he goes if you
call the cops now he's gonna be in jail
all weekend cuz it was a fine it I go
super [ __ ] away book it was go home I
just went home and then the next day I
know he got banned in the club and then
for three or four years after that every
time I would walk by him he would call
me a piece of [ __ ] and I wanted to say I
didn't do anything and but you guys have
finally patched this up I'm so sorry I
asked this or mentioned it out of
nowhere he calls me and he just goes
five years later hey dude it's alright
and I just want to go funky right but he
goes I know that you had nothing to do
with it and I was just emotional I love
you were you a little worried like a
fist was gonna come for time hahaha yeah
and also you're crumbling because I I
loved him mm-hmm he was my friend
yeah we were at a birthday party
together yeah at Spaghetti Factory
looking at a picture of a snicker bar up
your brother's hat ah oh my god we just
talked about that about that no one
as proof no one can find out I have its
guard in my brain would we like to do a
lobotomy and see now that oil because he
was there if you could vouch Eric
Stonestreet yeah I got my brother we
talked about that yeah it was really up
his button yeah yeah I got this far ah
yeah Laban had done that see Oh Annabeth
what a random order look at that the
Spaghetti Factory
I know by the way what they should
reopen a Spaghetti Factory there's one
there's one out in the Inland Empire
with its mirror what's it called again a
factory but where it's like an Claremont
or something about right yeah it's after
10 well we know at night Ryan
I love the manager's special what was it
is that the three flavor is two flavors
of sauces you can choose okay and the
two sauces you have to choose is the
mushroom sauce and I love the one with
the Masato cheese then we'll use you mix
or your meat sauce too you can mix it
together and Sandhya's little warm for
me what is so excited too so it's like I
love it
you make it sound good and I hate the
spaghetti vibration yeah Benihana -
that's means one know I come on I gotta
say something funny that actually has
happened that you don't know about so I
have made it because you're I think you
might have been the first person to ever
take me to Korean barbecue and I've you
know loved it and I've made it my
mission that every time I go to Korean
barbecue yeah I name my name drop you
yeah I just work it into the
conversation with the waiters everything
yeah this is a little fishing expedition
just to see if there's any reaction of
like Oh Bobby Regan you know he's a very
famous korean comedian
done right and no so the [ __ ] day I
went to ginn wha is that what it's
called yeah and why it's really good I
uh I said um where do you like to go I
like to the waiter I'm like so wordy
when you want Korean barbecue where do
you go
yeah and he goes all to k-town and I'm
like yeah but like specifically which
ones are good and he rattles a couple
off
and I said I've been to soup Baljeet
before he goes all yeah that's really
good that's you know it's I said they're
not that friendly they're too like white
guys like me does I don't know if they
also speak English or whatever I said
but my friend Bobby Lee
pause took me to the place right next to
kyochon right there with the pig emblem
and he goes oh yeah and he rattles it
off yeah yeah yeah
and he goes Oh Bobby Lee actually Bobby
Lee was injured one time he slapped one
of our waiters yeah finally my name is
Roger
AJ world slap the waiter yeah I don't
have to wait her it jinhwan God not but
not in a violent way oh I've never slept
not in an Ari Shaffir way yeah I know
and like you know made like hey that
kind of a way he had a huge spiritual
meltdown because our favorite Korean
barbecue spot has a wall it's an Asian
wall of fame and he is not in parks
parks Bobby Cox barbecue where's that
I'm on that one
are you are you you're [ __ ] mean I
[ __ ] up babe you [ __ ] man I'll pop
ya before me al Christmas oh yeah you
had my hair black put on a really no
yeah you know what we did what we had a
fan yeah from this podcast go to parks
you mean the fan yes and what bad one no
Anya frame a [ __ ] photo of me yes and
then [ __ ] put it on the wall is it
still up yes yes amazing and then when I
went back there like recently the owner
was out you had no long with the end
okay
I go here's the challenge what for your
fans yeah they have a certain time limit
let's give them Oh
six weeks okay good somebody needs to
get a picture of me parks bar yeah yes
and we'll go in there together
we'll go in together yeah six weeks I
have something I have there's a photo of
me and Eric on my Instagram I am oh this
one oh there's one from the past and
there's also one couple years ago do
that photo something recent frame it and
then put it on part
wall and don't say anything don't say
that's a challenge and if you can do
that what do we give them bed free
t-shirt possibly for you pal they also
have an upstairs wall where they put
like the d-list eleven I think that
Romero wall no that's where you end
before we ended up they more do any more
gonna go what goes bigger than that it's
a baseball player
oh yeah well excited you've never seen
anyone did I ever tell you I met the
dance song guy uh uh yeah William on my
side right yeah I caught for him he has
six photos of him on that wall I guess
40 was a really good photo 15 with you
baby on the back upper side I have a
little confrontation how the baseball
game would conjunct no no that's a
Korean betrayal invited me one time over
twice I've only I've invited you to I've
invited you to my Christmas party three
times you've showed up twice that's how
what you're talking about it's true I
didn't have it last year you didn't have
a last year no I'm having it next year I
get invited to soup yeah of course now
that I've met yeah well i'ma let me ask
you something so I'm you did yeah for
sure said I don't think so do you think
bigger maybe I think it's big now those
are just the weight it's not a weight
thing I just think it's fit have you
seen it so you never seen Eric spino is
that one of those guys you're not one of
those guys anything
I don't like seven I have a very shallow
vagina it's not going to work I need
smaller
okay I'm sick anymore not seeing anybody
right now
I mean not not as in a girlfriend
I don't agree what about having an opera
singer oh yeah you were getting an opera
singer oh I was dating a girl that was
on Broadway girl your finger oh yeah
what happened in icon yes we broke up
yeah yeah doing her thing I can't
imagine what your taste is like now well
as it taste before from what you saw I
mean to me he would be like you know and
he's an average
I probably got girls that were but now
I've never been quantity over quality
guy ever and yeah I know you're a
quality guy so I can't imagine whatever
worse didn't like hooking up with a girl
just because she was hook up with me
like right everybody you need the
insides to insides are important
sometimes Bobby I met my girl human on
tinder oh my god I can't I still can't
believe it myself remember when I would
start texting you right when I started
posting pictures of her I'm like does
that girl need help like look what do I
need to call the police
yeah are you holding her against her
will you don't find me that I'm a as it
I find you charming but I don't think
that I'm that tractive uh you're not my
type if I was gay no I mean if I like I
wouldn't bone you yeah that's rude why
that was gay I would probably go yeah
check this guy's thank you
well that's you and I made I mean how I
did if you were gay and I was gay would
you at least invite me to parties and
sauce like we planned with yeah yeah but
I would do a real big blanket like hey
this is my friend Bobby alright and you
would probably never recommend me to
your other gay friends yeah I would guys
that were into you know that Asians I
don't think you're fat oh that's nice
yeah yeah yeah well this would be
friends in that world yeah uh I remember
one time when I was shopping like with a
friend of mine at North Shore yeah got
mad and I was trying some stuff on this
was before modern family or anything and
we're trying to I was trying some
clothes on and I came out and my friend
Matt was like dude this the salesman
totally thinks were a couple he's like
oh really healing yeah and so I go back
in like and I try a couple other things
off our track other couple things on and
I come out and the salesman is so
clearly like flirting with Matt like
flirting with ya and I find myself like
getting really like mad about it because
they had told me that he thought we were
a couple so and I'm like well if he
thinks we're a couple like this is
really disrespectful today he's so big
when we finish up and we're walking away
like dude that guy totally totally was
hitting on me and basically
me to go out I'm like are you [ __ ]
like I want to go back and confront a
man but we're not gay but you you
thought we were and [ __ ] you for trying
Akane oh my god right it was and he
didn't find you attractive well he
wanted to bone that man yeah do you find
that let me because you do okay I have
seen a couple of modern families and I
know you've won Emmys and people have
said to me like you know that guy I go
yeah is he gay and I go because you're
so good on that show as that guy is that
weird out there or now it was in the
beginning a little bit but do people ask
you that I'm yeah I block anybody on it
I love blocking people on social media
so anybody that says are you gay in
their life I just block them because I
think that's a completely inappropriate
well I yeah yeah yeah like if I was your
the person I'm gonna come out to right
now yeah I know what thank you so much
for asking me Instagram [ __ ] off yeah
[ __ ] off yeah not it's not a question
but in the beginning it was weird
because you know like I never wanted to
seem like I was ashamed of being gay so
like if I wanted to talk to a girl I
couldn't go up to a girl be like hey
just so you know I'm not gay and I think
you're really cute like I would never
say that yeah that would imply that I
would care if you thought I worried that
there was something wrong with being gay
yeah it was a little bit of a you know
you're right that I am an average you
know guy and uh it was a deeper hole
that I already had to kind of dig myself
out of because I'm funny and charming
and it takes a minute for that to wash
over a girl they're not just deciding
that I want to bone that guy purely
based on his looks yeah so I had a
little bit more of a challenge in the
beginning but I overcame it I'm so
[ __ ] happy for you are we done no I
just wanted to say that oh but I think
that I uh I like sort of gay guys I mean
they're like I like men with I don't
have a little bit yeah a little bit yeah
alright fluidity I find that attractive
yeah and the point is is I'm I'm
confident enough of a man in my
masculinity did not care if a girl thing
exactly this unnecessary it's a
necessary even ask also the kabbala
Dukes was winning he knows that it means
carefully so angry everyone right now in
high school yeah I was younger I mean oh
I think I didn't know that I don't think
there's a soul that he doesn't want to
tell that story to I think I did
it's freeing to talk about it do you
remember you know you want to hear
something funny that I've always laughed
at and been embarrassed of at the same
time what an experience you and I had
together so one time I went down to San
Diego to watch you do comedy at The
Comedy Store down there oh yeah Dave
Attell was like the main guy there that
night like he was the whatever you call
it the headliner
yeah but not and I didn't know like
again not in the stand-up world so I
didn't know Dave Attell was like a
slayer of comedy I just thought he was a
comedian and was going to get up and do
it show yeah and he was out back and you
guys were kind of talking out back and
he was smoking a cigarette and he was
ready to go in and I went a man that
have a great show you know just yeah
being nice and he I'll never forget it
and it's a great [ __ ] line he goes
thanks old-timer
oh my god it was the [ __ ] best I was
like yeah not how I meant it but that
was [ __ ] incredible yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah he's back they'll be he
wasn't that big then but he was you you
really received an item already no I
mean I'd love yeah I mean one can love
him and I didn't know him is like what
he was you know a few years later he had
a sheet a B C and told them to pick up
my pilot uh what is it called again
spilling up take that there what do you
play I play I'm Oliver husband's best
friend in it well adorable how do you do
in it you were always worried about your
acting with me you would always tell me
that you I said I'll do it I'd say him
mission mm-hmm I just I just go cuz I do
some love to on Netflix I always go
shiny to me you know it was a terrible
day yeah but you wouldn't be there if
that was true I understand I know I just
I did something that I bought myself I
have to confront you right and like you
know I have to be careful at some point
at some point people I'm sorry go ahead
it's just a self-fulfilling prophecy at
this point I know leader I know
so that's all I know and the other
danger you really get into yeah with so
many people in our business is you
really run the risk of people just
thinking you're narcissist and want
attention all the time that's true we
talked about this last week you know who
does that says that about me Whitney
Cummings
she's probably not wrong she's like
you're a narcissist I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] he
is saying [ __ ] like that yeah you just
want constant but but I've known you
long enough to know that it is a real
it's it's somewhat based in reality no
and a lot of the fear and a lot of like
traumatic auditions that you I know
everyone just listen what I swear to
[ __ ] god I know that I'm being better
you mean the good actor
I know but gets listened to I bet I know
that in this pilot that I do well really
yeah I know that yeah because because
you're dying little what you're doing
less no I'm just like more I'm listening
and I'm doing more of that one of me I
yeah yeah you're doing less yeah and I'm
being in the scene and they really love
what I'm doing and I know that I'm doing
a good job new directors um to my friend
Dean I didn't test one you just got it
yeah see ya
so many actors and people and performers
that are listening to this podcast and
you can you know not complaining but you
expressing your worry and your fear of
not being good
you can't couple that with I didn't
audition or test for it those two things
don't jive because that's when people
that have real struggles in our business
check I know
all right I get it yeah all right I
would have change no you're not I am
change clothes where we at I work right
out over 50 I can't get listen now this
is what happens now so having the show's
over no we could have one last thing we
have a email a physical question but
hold on just a minute how long did you
go do this with me like Callen you guys
could probably go on for hours for all
of you the longest you ever went was
probably an hour 20 minutes with you
okay like maybe Jordan Peele Jordan
criolla Wow what I mean I want to break
the record what do you mean I'm just
saying here's why I do it that way
though and I know the people listening
right now go how come you always say
we what time we're because we want to
hear two hours I always believe less is
more like therapy session yes and I
believe that when I do anything I try to
compact the thing with as much
entertainment within a small amount of
space
yeah but how do you know an hour and 20
with me isn't going to be but you know
you don't exhaust ydynt your your
energies match you have a frenetic
energy you're calm so it can go on for a
while you have to people with United
phonetic to write I give what I get oh
so you'll get your good right now
because I'm giving good no I'm saying
that I am able to match my scene partner
like if I can just you know decide what
what Wow
person me wow so you're you're a high
level right no no I'm I'm right here in
the middle because right your show oh
you ever gonna do a podcast
no it's for us for people David yeah
no it's not that's not why I what are
you mad baby no no but I'm that's what I
meant yeah oh my god like that's what I
yeah no I wouldn't I wouldn't do it
because I get why I never did stand like
stand up in that I don't know that I
have that the energy and passion to be
good at hosting a weekly podcast and I
don't want to just start saying I'm
gonna do a podcast now because I'm on a
show I write back people more than Eric
but I swear to [ __ ] god I know that
you could do it dude was a podcast or
stand-up because you have the connection
of point of view you know how to add
information people are always rise by
how angry I am in real life that's the
one thing I'm constantly competing
against my character yeah my characters
really fun and nice and I'm I'm I'm I'm
nice but I have a more of an angry point
of view in life and it really get your
edge here I was telling them if he's a
little edgy he can you know but I don't
think that I've been very nice hey you
can't go you're great tonight I've been
very nice you
this is you know me and this is the dead
in it very nice I want to see the rain
have you been in a fistfight before
yeah yeah oh sit yeah all right I
wouldn't see the angry side you don't
have to be a real friendly baby you
don't want to unleash it I love angry
people they're my favorite what do you
want oh dude I don't want anything sir
outside no when you were telling that
story like I would have had a real
conflict in that moment because I'm
thinking two things where was everybody
else when Ari Shaffir was hitting you
because had I been with you that night I
would have gone [ __ ] red light like I
would yeah yeah I mean least my question
but here's so Natasha came to the store
four months after that very Martin's
with her still yeah yeah and Eric took a
[ __ ] glass of water with ice in it
threw it at her threw it in her face
guard two [ __ ] eyes one on our face
oh my god and then dub gave it off and
bryan callen were there and they got up
and they [ __ ] put you know me start
put it was like but they were there when
I got beat up Steve on his Izzy you know
I mean I'm floating the bone I'm friend
with both she's like I don't know what
to do I don't know who that person is he
was in the league okay yeah I'm glad
yeah I'm so glad you said that - well I
might if I saw him I don't need a
question what's the question on hopeful
advice with Bobby
Kalama at 7 inches of stone in the
country course for kalila for kalila
purposes I'm a 90 year old girl in
Canada and I have recently been
diagnosed with Asperger's it has been
extremely hard to wrap my head around it
and to accept i've always felt different
but now I feel like I have a huge label
across my head saying autistic having
Asperger's helps me realize why I've
never been good at making connections to
other people that being said I have
never had any romantic connections just
from the lack of social skills and
extreme social anxiety my question is
how should I go about getting out there
in the dating world
I feel so behind of all my peers in this
aspect and other aspects in life and if
when do I start dating how and when do I
go about the subject of my diagnosis my
name is Anna
how old see at 19 I wasn't aware that
Asperger's was still a diagnosis
actually I thought it was just a autism
she's on you guys right yeah dr. Liu is
an extreme spectrum that's it yeah it
can go from anything from low function
very functional which are you a little
bit yeah are people who are absolutely
no communication skills at all so it's a
very wide range I'm sorry all right
and she's probably very bright yeah the
other spectrum the other side of the
spectrum is obviously the savant
to where I think the answer to anybody
that's like looking for some sort of
romance these days is online dating I
just I think that really is there's no
stigma to that anymore in you know
pictures you just got to put yourself
out there you have to make the decision
to get yourself out there and that is
the easiest way to get yourself out
there yeah and I don't think that you
should lead with that insecurity either
it is you have it you own it and you
know it doesn't define you yeah it
doesn't and it's it's it's not a
hindrance either it can be also if she
is because I'm a koala and she goes I
have Asperger's I know what is it and
she'll tell me I don't think that it
would make me feel weird
I mean I have I sometimes I do think I
fall under the spectrum I know a lot of
like I ticks and I I'd link anxiously a
lot I have severe I have weird things
about me and ticks that other this [ __ ]
that I do I have ticks to waiting on
okay I gotta get going good podcast yeah
yeah we have problems
okay what's the other question oh okay
uh so that's video and I like questions
more questions with it so I'm 17 years
old and I have herpes I don't know how
to direct it worse okay I don't know and
I like that one I like that one I don't
know how to deal with it any advice on
how to communicate with people that I
might be with in the future
what is herpes okay it's a virus that
lives I know what it I'm pretty sure
you're familiar yeah yeah
please don't say that cuz then that she
has it yeah happily I know what I always
say well two girls
can you get more herpes yeah yeah can
you I mean you can have hsv-1 which is
like not the very obvious or painful
reoccurring once throughout your whole
life that's like the ones in your mouth
but you can also get down there they're
not the outbreaks are not as like
intense you have super aids but then
they have HSB to which really you've
heard of super duper aid we've never
heard of that yes you can get it is that
real yeah super AIDS I think I heard it
well HIV I did I think I heard it yeah
Jesus Christ but herpes you know who
doesn't have to brave a awesome eight
out of 10 people by the time they're a
certain age probably have the virus
inside of them whether or not it chooses
to you know show itself which is awesome
so yeah so that's the testicle what's
your name her mommy are you are happy
harmony yes you but you know yeah you
know on the herpe thing I mean
transparency is always 100% the best
policy in anything you'll ever come
along with in your life the conversation
of admittance will be much less
difficult than the conversation of
what's the word guilt yeah you know when
you when something's found out I mean
you just got to start with it and it's
it's super common like yeah very common
and use protected you know you're going
to protect yourself you're seventeen
don't know that you should even be doing
it yet anyway living an honest life star
is always like I said know a lot of
comics that rock around really nice they
[ __ ] around behind their wives back or
whatever and I I do say I thought do it
it's kind of come back yeah up cut yeah
I don't know why you live like that and
you did a lot of these guys are doing
well I always say you want to be the
Train excuse me I always say
you want to pull a train goddammit I did
I always say you want to be the engine
on the train not the caboose I want to
be driving the situation and not being
drug along in the wake of it girl yeah
so that that's a good note to end on
herpes kirpan make note yeah Eric you
what up you know you know what to plug
in anything of a movie coming out a
couple TV shows have you seen the toy
box the show that I'm doing on ABC when
does this air when's this gonna be on
tonight or not oh so the toy box is on
Friday nights on ABC that's and that's
an example of how I've recently had to
realize that I'm competing against my
own character that I play on TV because
I'm hosting the show as myself and the
reason I'm hosting the show the reason I
even said yes to doing it was because it
was an opportunity for me to sort of be
my dry you know sense of humor with
people but people watch the show and be
like I like your accessories as an actor
but not as a host and it's because they
don't know my personality yeah but
you're so [ __ ] funny as a person I
don't really rarely I know that you're
killing it on that gel but I only know
you as a naturally intrinsically funny
guy legit that's a honestly a big big
compliment from for me from you I really
do mean that yeah because I've always
felt like there's like I went to a Funny
or Die party after Modern Family was on
and I did feel like because I'm on in
like a network television show and I'm
on that and it's you know like gets good
ratings and wins awards that somehow I'm
not in the cool comedy club yeah we talk
about this all the time
Elkanah are you something right now
yeah and I promise you this we all want
to be where you're at I told her when I
booked this pilot I just said we might
get invited to the party cuz I've been
to the party if I get to be at the club
right right you're in the club and let
me tell you something right now there is
a difference you're at a level that's
completely different untouched
untouchable but but I did feel like I
felt like the senior in like it I was
made that I and it was a
on me because most people in the your
world don't know me as stand up because
I wasn't or as an improviser because you
know how many people saw me improvise
for 12 years you know so I oh I felt
like that the comedy people don't look
at me as a comedy guy they just look at
me as a guy I got lucky and is now on a
network I like let me ask you this
Jordan Peele do you know him yeah do you
know him before you did Modern Family of
course yeah he's legitimate yeah 100 per
second
yes you knew him hilarious like yeah
yeah I mean there's a list of people
that are killing it right now that
already know that what you can do and
who you were and you didn't need modern
family to get have them have that
opinion of you Yeah right so [ __ ] [ __ ]
up well no but you know what I mean
about the the it did come I know I mean
I you know I've always hated them let me
say this I've been doing stand-up for 20
years I've never been the Montreal
Comedy Festival really yeah
and it's like at at some point you just
have to go I'm not but fine yeah but it
s [ __ ] fine it's fine but you're
Europe so you're an improviser so let me
tell you the main main thing real quick
and then I'll let you guys go sorry I'm
talking about not so how y'all hear
something that I've noticed about comedy
is it used to be when I was in Chicago
and starting off there at the
ImprovOlympic and I would talk to guys
that were had been improvising for a
long time you would go out onto the
street and the climate at IO
is that it's just bits galore and just
you're standing outside smoking a
cigarette drinking water doing whatever
it is in its bit bit bit bit bit and
everyone says yes yes yes yes yes and
you just do the bit and you have no idea
what's going to come from that bit
usually nothing
sometimes something now what I feel like
is is you'll be around like let's say a
couple I oh guys like guys like me and
perform on beer shark mice and those
those guys that will just jump in and do
this you'll be around doing bitumen add
a little with a cool guy comedy club in
and the cool guy comedy is sitting back
and thinking like well I'm going to
judge the bit first yeah and I'm going
to decide whether I think the bits funny
and then I'm gonna jump into the bed
yeah and I'm gonna kill the [ __ ] that's
what it feels like where the whole
spirit of improv and what the beauty of
Io is is bits just are that they're bits
and you say yes to them yeah with no
judgment yeah that's what I feel like it
to me the difference is is there's
judgement where there didn't used to be
yeah but also those people that judge
the horses they can't hear right so off
yeah why tell you had the pocket okay
have you ever been over to salute leg
baby hey that's a prime real estate
there's no farts going on over there
they have a computer not fair I like
they sure do yeah we can put a poquito
mas in my baby you would never betray me
in that way I would never I know you
will Ian show Norway Lima and Norwood
potential isla oh yeah I like that she
said uh maybe you've said this before on
the podcast that you have a shallow
very shallow vision which is good for
you and write really well so good real
good
sometimes I hit the half of them yeah
all the way about halfway no I don't hit
the wall I go halfway though yeah yeah
anyway uh thank you Eric for coming by
[Applause]
we'll be right back guys a cleaning
house and we're back Eric Stonestreet
what a guy I like him I like him a lot
starstruck I can't believe how long
they've known each other yeah like since
the late 90s I think she's so many
commercials
hell yeah Bobby you could tell me like
he's the absolute king of commercials no
I feel like his look too and just have
fun he is for sure books all the time
yeah it made sense that's really good
advice that he gave about like going
into the commercial auditions you just
got to not give a [ __ ] and then they
give a [ __ ] about you yeah because I
think that you do sense that like a
sense of desperation is really
off-putting if I was a casting director
I somebody just hits it perfectly and
they're like it's really great to meet
you and like man get the [ __ ] out of
here I can't do that I need someone with
a little bit of
like rough around the edges where I
could see him okay he wasn't perfect but
I can see it going there that was like
definitely mean Chicago's I didn't know
and I was come a big smile hey Gilbert
like the [ __ ] fake bull yeah yeah I
really like no callbacks and as soon as
I started being like hey what's up guys
chill yeah it's like Oh normal person
here's a callback for being a just a
[ __ ] normal person you know that's
like Steve Lee he's Chris Beckham has
booked so many commercials is because
Steve Lee genuinely doesn't care and he
just goes in he's like I don't want to
[ __ ] be here but I'm gonna do it yeah
and he always gets a callback that make
sense I thought about going into
auditions just for that
just for that reason but I'm scared I'd
get a callback I just me for the
experience of like not giving a [ __ ]
yeah and then as soon as I got a
callback for something big ah ah ah I'm
sorry I stir a while I let's say you get
a callback it's hard not to care at that
point then you're like okay I got it I
want to do better that's what I'm trying
to fix now yeah callback is the first
one like I'm probably not going to get
it yeah the callback then that's when
the nerves kick in yeah right too hard
yeah good advice Jim so hey guys I want
to take a moment to thank everybody that
came out to our live show last Thursday
it was an absolute blast I I got to meet
most of you I think and it was everybody
was just super cool super nice super
impressive and I want to say that I love
you guys everybody that I did meet and
it was a nice night yeah everyone
looking for that super super nice and
for those who didn't make it to this
show don't worry we'll have several more
in the future and they'll be bigger and
better get ready for a Europe tour and
thank you to everybody who helped out
you know who you are so I appreciate you
right I also want to take a moment to
give a shout out to our two great
interns Johnny and and Gustavo who put
in a lot of work for that night and to
Annabelle and John na and George and
Bobbie just reentered the room Omar was
just there yeah Omar and Russell were
there in case in case I needed extra
help and so guys uh we
black shirts are sold out on our website
we only have a handful of the white
shirts left so if you had been keen on
grabbing the slept King shirt do it now
cuz on any low-level job Bobby just
decided to go back on the mic it's weird
having you there I think we should have
this new set up we use it there Johnny
Gustavo oh that'd be fun with some of
you who are they yeah I'm very
interested go Bobby any tolerate on the
live show as I watch the live show what
happened you were there
live show Bobby all our fans a class
there's no wonderful times there's a
really good time Jim you know I don't
know I shouldn't got naked that was
weird living you live and you learn you
live in your learn um let's do some ads
yeah so yeah guys make sure you follow
us on instagram at tiger belly all right
when I eat I love these fine on Twitter
at that AgrAbility most any questions at
the Tiger belly at you apron gmail.com
so yeah my shoes I go to answer no we
already did them super tada frame bridge
go to frame bridge calm and remember the
promo code is belly alright we'll see
you guys later like my glove oh wait
hang on we're not done oh sorry look I I
need to plug Bobby's dates oh yeah go
ahead
okay hang on let me pull up my list
before I I forget I'm so irresponsible
come on Khalil you're better than this
okay guys if you want to go see Bobby do
stand-up he will be at hilarities in
Cleveland June 1st to the 3rd parlor
live in Seattle or in Bellevue June 8th
through the 10th comedy zone in
Charlotte that's North Carolina right so
June 22nd to the 24th Tempe Arizona June
22 the 22nd and Salt Lake City July 28th
through 29th I am for I haven't updated
his site yet but I will
so four more dates go to Bobby Lee
lyakhov
Morocco doing comic love August
all right so show guys
[Music]